some news also came out about Jed a
front-runner a report that he had a
girlfriend up to right before going on
the show everyone does is that I mean it
seems to me like we get the story every
season and yet people freak out about it
every season now what do you both saying
I guess when I heard that I was like
yeah I was waiting for that like I was
waiting for someone to have a girlfriend
happens every season but I mean it can't
judge anyone for it because sometimes
you really have no idea you're gonna
fall off on that show and you're like
you know what I'm gonna go here for the
opportunity maybe I'll see you when I
get back yeah and we'll see what happens
and then you go and you actually find
love and you're like whoa I didn't think
that was gonna happen so it's not like
he he might have you know had he
admitted he had different intentions
going into the show yeah so so I stuck
when when Jed had said that his
intentions were to go on the show and
promote his music business I stuck up
for him because I thought it was great
to be proactive about what you're doing
and how that has changed but I think if
you now correlate him openly putting it
out there that his only intention was to
promote his music business and then you
couple that with some of the comments
that his girlfriend are now saying about
the night before and then you tie in the
twist of the gentleman who was there the
night before the night one who had a
girlfriend right and you saw Hanna's
reaction then you go down that road of
people saying well Hanna what kind of
standards do you have and and she's
gonna have to address all that so you
guys are busy bees yeah living in
Nashville together does it feel like
you're living together yet or deep
travel so much for working to all these
things that it hasn't sunk in yet I feel
like we have been traveling so much yes
I moved in I still need to unpack
everything yeah so the days we have had
there have been fantastic and we wake up
with coffee and we joke around we have
this Power Hour we sit down and like
talk about business things of what we
have going on and we'll end our hender
night with a glass of wine and I've
enjoyed every minute of it yeah I mean
are you ending your night yeah thank you
oh great does it feel to freaking have
your own
why honestly it is a dream come true I'm
not just saying that since I had my
first tip of why never in life I was
like like this is this is what I'm
supposed to be doing like everything in
my life has led me to have a wine label
this man everything and it's just like
oh here we are we have arrived